are your medicine reject or did you want
to do medicine i might measure some aj
yes yes
i was a dentistry reject
[Music]
hello and welcome i'm zaiha today i took
the train down to go to my friend's
graduation ceremony
and i'll be asking the most
stereotypical question biomedical
students get did you get rejected from
medicine
these students actually finished their
biomed degree a year ago but they could
only celebrate it a year after due to
covert so i asked them what they've been
up to in the last year since finishing
their degree
and what kind of career path could they
follow with their biomedical sciences
degree
[Music]
side notes i realize the questions i ask
are very blunt but this is only for
entertainment purposes so please don't
take it seriously and enjoy
[Music]
so congratulations on your graduation
thank you thanks thank you
thank you thank you so what course did
you do so what degree did you do my
undergrad i did medical sciences i did
medical sciences here at exeter medical
science uh university of accident i did
neuroscience at exeter where we are lab
caucus research medical research i did
medical sciences and how has your day
been so far really nice to have all
these people celebrating three years of
hard work and stress and fun and so many
emotions obviously i have to process it
i'm very happy to finally graduated
seeing a lot of friends especially after
the pandemic i'm being able to see a lot
of friends so it's great catch up as
well it's been great honestly i wish the
weather was a bit sunnier but you know
take what comes
exactly what are you doing with your
life right now what are you doing with
your life right now so for the last year
i've been studying the gdl which is
basically the law conversion course so
you can convert from any course to law
in a year through that i've been
applying to different jobs and stuff and
i've just secured like a paralegal role
in london um so i'm gonna be a child
brain paralegal which is really exciting
wow that's really cool so now i'm
currently going to do dentistry from
september at the university of aberdeen
so i'm a medical life assistant where i
deal with human samples coming from all
the areas around the hospital i work for
a doctor has a podcast and an app i do
background research and i write scripts
i do some scientific communication and
research right now i'm doing medicine as
an undergrad exeter university i'm in
first year and i'm working in the nhs
there's a operating theatre system are
your medicine reject or did you want to
do medicine i might measure some reject
yes yes
no
no i wasn't i was a
thought
dentistry
reject
yeah i did want to do a medicine
unfortunately i did get rejected before
i was eventually reject hashtag go
cardiff
i did i think a lot of people that did
neuroscience wanted to i applied for
medicine around the uk originally then a
levels came through and i was like nope
i ended up coming to the neuroscience
center which was i think beneficial i
think it's helped in 2023 hopefully i'm
getting to medicine okay hopefully good
luck you got this thank you thank you
well i'm going in october i'm going to
do medicine in georgia tibilisi i spent
a year thinking should i go abroad
should i do masters and a phd or should
i do medicine in the uk after weighing
my options it seems like doing medicine
abroad was the best option i applied for
medicine first
and now i'm not sure anymore i
definitely love the knowledge i know i
love the knowledge of it i know i would
enjoy the course do you think most
people in medical sciences are medicine
rejects or what is your opinion on that
i think initially a lot of people wanted
to do medicine but i think people grew
like a love for medical sciences i think
a lot of people go into it with the idea
of doing medicine i think a good
majority are people in biomedical
sciences did initially want to do
medicine but to be honest there's a good
amount of people that are just wanting
to go into medical sciences as a degree
but i feel like doing the degree
sometimes makes you realize that it
wasn't what you wanted to do originally
really and it's kind of just general
route that people know about and we
don't really know about other careers so
it's kind of like medicine law all these
things that's what we know about so
that's what we go to when we're 18. but
then when you do the degree you realize
that there's so much else there's so
many more options and careers that we
can do so there's people who want to do
research so it depends by doing the
biomedical science degree it's a good
gateway to medicine or to graduate
medicine as well but yeah originally
there's probably quite a few medical
objects for sure yeah
and lastly did you ever want to do
medicine did you want to do medicine no
so i personally never wanted to do
medicine i was always kind of more
interested in like human biology like
disease so obviously if you do medicine
you don't have to want to do medicine
exactly yes all right thank you so much
it was lovely to talk to you
thank you so much and enjoy the rest of
your day thank you thank you thank you
enjoyed the rest of your day thank you
enjoy yours i hope you have a lovely
rest of the day
thank you thank you thank you
thank you so much for watching please do
hit the subscribe button and if you'd
like to see what i get up to on my
general surgery rotation make sure to
check out the next video i'll see you in
the next one
[Music]